if interest rates go up to six percent  which right now it's roughly 5.7  that same 500 000 loan is now 29.98  roughly 3 000  and if you continue paying that at six  percent it would take you million  seventy nine thousand dollars to pay off  a five hundred thousand dollar loan now  interest rates  if they get to nine percent some people  say that's not going to happen we're  gonna look at numbers to see if it's  gonna happen or not  if it gets to nine percent same five  hundred thousand dollar house  it's not gonna cost you twenty one  hundred dollars it's not going to cost  you twenty nine hundred dollars it's  going to cost you four thousand twenty  three  dollars which is one million  four hundred and forty eight thousand  dollars to pay off a five hundred  thousand dollars